la chine face aux questions des
dirigeants internationaux des doutes
sont émis au moment où de nouveaux
chiffres apparaissent dans la région de
roanne
les précisions de grégoire hotz des
zones d'ombré qui appelle à des
éclaircissements
ces dernières heures londres paris et
washington ont exprimé publiquement
leurs doutes quant à la gestion de
l'épidémie par les autorités chinoises
un manque de transparence pointé du
doigt alors que la mairie de bourg ain
vient de revoir à la hausse le nombre de
victimes du coronavirus 1290 décès
supplémentaires portant le bilan
officiel de la chine à 4630 de victimes
ces chiffres rendent perplexes certains
dirigeants de puissances occidentales à
commencer par les états unis qui ont
annoncé lancer une enquête
nous menons une enquête approfondie sur
tout ce que nous pouvons pour savoir
comment ce virus est échappée s'est
répandue dans le monde et a été à
l'origine de tant de tragédies tant de
morts ici aux etats-unis et dans le
monde entier avec également un coût
énorme pour l'économie mondiale une
demande de transparence
appuyé par dominique rabe qui assure
actuellement l'intérim de boris johnson
à la tête du gouvernement britannique
nous avons une très bonne coopération
avec les chinois notamment pour le
retour des ressortissants britanniques
de lujan nous devrions donc examiner
tous les aspects de la question et de
manière équilibrée nous devront poser
des questions difficiles sur la manière
dont elle a démarré et sur comment elle
aurait pu être arrêté plus tôt le
président français emmanuel macron a lui
aussi affiché sa méfiance à propos de la
gestion de la crise par pékin il ya
manifestement des choses qui se sont
passées qu'on ne sait pas en réponse à
cette série de questionnements zaho
liane porte parole de la diplomatie
chinoise a réfuté toute dissimulation
au début objectivement il ya eu quelques
rapports tardif des omissions et des
informations inexactes cela peut
s'expliquer par l'insuffisance des
capacités d'admission et de traitement
dans les hôpitaux par le fait que
certains établissements médicaux n'ont
pas réussi à se connecter au système
d'information sur la prévention et le
contrôle des maladies en temps utile par
la surcharge des hôpitaux et par le fait
que le personnel médical était occupé à
traiter les patients mais il n'y a
jamais eu de 10,6
mullah sion et nous n'autoriserons
jamais aucune dissimulation reste à
savoir si ce démenti atténuera la
controverse au moment où les doutes
s'accumulent sur l'origine du virus